straight ahead on lawn crime Deli after
weeks and weeks of testimony the jury
will finally have the chance to talk
about the case against ynw Melly it'll
be up to 12 people to decide if the
rapper killed two of his best friends or
if he should walk free we're taking you
through the closing arguments from both
sides
in that rear seat
the person who committed this
question is who
so I'm going to show you now why the
state has proven
who was Jamel Dennis
you folks are going to going to
determine this young man's fate
and they come in here and give you
Alternatives lawn crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everybody to Lone crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber the jury officially has
the ynw Melly murder case and the
deliberations have begun on Thursday the
attorneys on both sides had their last
chance to argue the rapper's guilt or
innocence Mellie whose real name is
Jamel demons is accused of killing two
of his closest friends the deadly
shooting happened inside of an SUV in
the Fort Lauderdale area of South
Florida in 2018. he was seen on
surveillance getting into a Jeep with
Cortland Henry Christopher Thomas and
Anthony Williams as other friends got
into a red Mitsubishi now at some point
during the drive to Devin's home the
defendant says he got out of the Jeep
and into that Mitsubishi and not long
after that Henry showed up at a hospital
with Thomas and Williams bleeding in the
car they were both pronounced dead Henry
told investigators that there was a
drive-by shooting but police say they
determined the deadly shots were fired
from inside the car they charged both
demons and Henry with murder claiming
demons was the shooter in the back seat
demons could face the death penalty if
he's convicted did the prosecution gave
their closing argument first prosecutor
Christine Bradley used her time to
remind jurors of the evidence against
demons with a focus on forensics
the law is clear that this defendant
committed two counts of first degree
murder
I now have the opportunity to explain
all of the evidence this chemical reacts
no matter how many years later no matter
what attempt at cleanup is done
the chemical is still going to react to
the presence of the blood so then you
have
that reaction
and that reaction ladies and gentlemen
tells you
that someone is sitting in the seat
because as Detective Williams
Illustrated
it's where the blue star isn't so there
is no blood
there's no blood for someone's
would have been sitting
there's no blood where their legs would
have been and you can see on the
that's indicated on that and there's no
blood on the back
of the seed
so ladies and gentlemen what does that
tell you
pillar was sitting there
so the red Mitsubishi didn't stop
there's a 30 minutes 30 miles are
consistent with one another
that there was no stopping on the side
of the road
and also there's no reason
there is no reason it's been foot before
this during whatsoever
not in the phone records
not in Snapchat
nothing that explains why eight people
that are going to the exact same
location
would stop on the side of the road
it's one person would switch a car
no reason whatsoever ladies and
gentlemen you have a confession in this
case
4 pm
I did that
with the smiley face ladies and
gentlemen I would ask
that you serve Justice
that you delivery
and that you retired a verdict of guilty
as charged as to murder in the first
degree
all right let's talk about it I'm
joining right now by my co-host defense
attorney Brian buckmeyer and our special
guest former Federal prosecutor Nima
Romani great to have you both here and
email start with you you were a
prosecutor what'd you think of Christine
Bradley's closing
Jesse I gotta be honest I was a bit
underwhelmed I expected more it was a
strong case you know and I think the
defense did a good job in their
summation you know as a prosecutor in
rebuttal I like the sandbag a little bit
keep some of my best points and I think
the mistakes that were made here is she
needed to pound the confession pound
that cell phone evidence I think she was
on the defensive spent too much time
trying to explain away some of the
questions that the defense raised in
their closing so you know talk about the
victims talk about the evidence and
again Hammer that point home I think
really she ended with a little bit of a
whimper as opposed to a bang there well
Nemo is not convinced Brian but let's
play devil's advocate here let's say you
know they focused on some key points
like bullet trajectory the alleged
confession for the defense what do they
have to do to combat what the
prosecution put forward the defense has
to come in and poke holes where they've
already established that there are
potential holes in the case attack the
investigation attack the investigation
in a way that says they could have done
more and if they had done more then they
would have more answers and the lack of
of answers equals Reasonable Doubt
continue down that pathway go through
each one of the questions myself though
I would also attack some of the math
here yes that outline shows that someone
is there great but you don't have no
idea whether or not they stopped I mean
you and I were talking just quickly 30
miles in 30 minutes so you think they're
going 60 miles an hour then you think
they're driving the speed limit maybe
they stop for a second and kept speeding
on that's easy to kind of combat don't
open yourself up to arguments like that
well let's see if they listen to your
advice or you know after the fact
because we have a lot more to cover
after this break including what the
defense had to say in their closing
arguments but first we want to bring you
part of Thursday's q a session where we
take your viewer questions correspondent
Terry Austin has been inside the
courtroom for all of the action and
answered a question from a YouTube
viewer
so let's get to our next question
Latasha Gaffney from YouTube the
prosecutor said Melly didn't want to
leave any witness behind so why didn't
he kill Cortland Henry do you think the
jury is going to ask the same question
do you think they caught that part so I
will send that one over to you Terry
so I think what the prosecution is
trying to say as far as that is
concerned is Melly wanted the other two
juvie and Sack Chaser gone because he
didn't want to split up the money with
them but he felt as though Henry had his
back that was one of the messages she
read to the jury during her closing
argument so I'm assuming that her Theory
here is he left Henry alive because he
was more of an asset than the others now
you know if you believe her motive for
these is you know the greed the
resentment then she's saying that he did
not have Melly the defendant did not
have any greed or resentment or any of
those things as far as Henry was
concerned so that's why he allowed him
to live according to the prosecution
thank you
[Music]
and welcome back everybody so the jury
started deliberations Thursday afternoon
in the case of rapper ynw Melly whose
real name is Jamel demons he's charged
with two counts of murder after his two
friends were shot and killed in South
Florida five years ago in her last
segment we talked about some of the
biggest moments from the prosecution's
closing argument demons defense team
only spent about an hour delivering
their closing argument and made sure to
point out all the problems with the
state's case
how does a reasonable doubt occur well
the judges told you it can come
from the evidence itself
a conflict in the evidence or a lack of
evidence
you don't need all three of these areas
but I suggest to you folks
that we have a
Reasonable Doubt from the evidence that
has been presented
that there is a conflict in the evidence
and there's a lack
October 26th
that day of the shooting
we learn immediately that that jeep was
taken to a secure area
and it was searched for over 15 hours
by two crime scene technicians
and you heard
how they pulled out the evidence that
some phone some projectiles I think a
can everything and photographed the
vehicle now why is that important that
vehicle was searched again
months later
but it didn't stop there
because about three years later
miraculously even though it was searched
for hours by crime scene technicians
Sergeant Williams comes into the scene
at the request of the State of Florida
the this particular prosecutor right
here
and miraculously he finds additional
evidence to projectiles and a blood
stain that obviously everyone else
missed
that should tell you something about the
quality of this investigation
they told you
that they have
accepted the responsibility
that they have the burden of proof
they told you that they would prove each
element
of this case
what they have proved to you
is
but Cortland Henry is involved in this
case
and that's what I want to focus on so
Nema Stuart eddleston he pointed
multiple times toward Cortland Henry is
the real culprit you think that's a good
strategy
I think it's a great strategy Justin we
knew this is something that was going to
happen obviously the defense they always
like to point their finger at someone
else and when you have a co-defense who
better person than that that's why
defendants like to sever these trials
because the defenses tend to be
inconsistent so if you're the
prosecution you have to anticipate this
coming and you got to tell the jurors
listen even if we don't know who pulled
the trigger whether whether it was Melly
or Henry it doesn't matter you know at
least for the the guilt phase maybe
that's for the penalty but you know
you're an accomplished or a
co-conspirator you're responsible for
the murder so I wish the state spent a
lot more time on that because again it's
something that I think is very important
and something that they should have
anticipated and talking about the state
Brian we know that the prosecution
actually responded uh to the defense's
closing argument in a real quick
rebuttal argument
um they also I was curious what your
thoughts are and what the points they
made if you thought it was effective and
also can the jury consider manslaughter
yeah so overall I wasn't too impressed
the prosecution's rebuttal and uh like
this as a defense attorney the one thing
that I'm really jealous about for
prosecutors they get the final word and
I feel like she had that opportunity to
really come back and smack down a lot of
the arguments that the defense put out
but it seemed weak at point it seems
just a rehashing of what she had already
said rather than dismantling what the
defense was arguing and then to the
manslaughter part we all kind of was
like what's going on here because the
judge gave them the Lesser included
manslaughter charge which the prosecutor
should have argued for then in the
middle of her her closing argument in
the rebuttal she says
this is what manslaughter means
that someone takes on or perpetrates and
it just causes someone's death there's
no real premeditation there but she said
this is not manslaughter she totally
threw away the the answer included that
she had won there
he's going for all or nothing with the
murder and I mean manslaughter would be
interesting it would mean like something
happened in that car that caused him to
do that which would be very interesting
because that really hasn't been argued
one way or another so that's interesting